i am so excited to have the chance to
share my passion
for design and decorating with you in
another life i would have been
a full-on interior designer i'm obsessed
with creating fun new spaces
and redecorating my home friends homes
and now maybe
some of your homes if i could be so
lucky this is our first ever
designed by drew okay essential workers
have become the backbone of the country
this year
and we have so much to thank them for
one family right here in our backyard
has been selfless during this time as
all
five members have been going to work
every single day
please meet the copenings
don't let this you know us sitting down
here fool you we are a crazy bunch
we are just electric at times you know
everybody's a little spicy in their own
way and we just love to have a good time
you know you never know what to expect
in a coconut house
my name is michael copeland aka
chocolate thunderbaby
i'm lachelle namabeer aka shelly
michael copeland junior aka mike mike so
good you gotta say it twice
shaquille copenhan i am the middle child
and the favorite child
and i'm j aka j smoove the baby
we are the company
me my husband my children were all
essential workers
i am a united states postal clerk i knew
i was a front line worker when i looked
at all my neighbors and they wasn't
going to work
but i do somebody got to take care of
the sick so if i don't do my job then
somebody else can't do their job
mike mike was like me a directional
transportation technician
you may not know what it is but it's a
bus operator that's my son y'all
you have my daughter she's in the board
of education
she takes care of the kids jay quan he
works in a nursing home
i'm grateful that we were not physically
affected
by the the virus it really had me
so worried and so concerned at first i
didn't take the culvert too serious
until i learned that i lost a close
co-worker
made me just say this is for real that's
one of the things of being a front line
essential worker
is that you know you're not only worried
about the people that you're in the
house with but you're worried about
the people that they're connected to at
my nursing home
i was close to many residents who passed
away it was this one resident that
i really got close to probably my best
friend there
he got really sick and all the nurses
and everything
thought it was over for him and i prayed
for him
i had my whole family pray for him and
he actually made it
through we are a family that supports
one another so if one of us is down and
somebody needed prayer so
we all band together as a family and we
said we're gonna pray for that person
during the pandemic i felt it was just
more than just
taking people to work it was just who i
was taking to work
bringing in the front line workers
officers
nurses doctors you know all the above
this summer for hero day i
wore an mta uniform because i wanted to
celebrate the fact that my brother
and my dad were out there every day
driving essential workers to work and
i wanted to celebrate them because they
were my heroes
the house that we're in right now is a
very special place to me
i was born and raised there and now i
have the pleasure
of raising my kids in the same house so
we all have the same experiences
during this pandemic we have to find new
safe places for our family to spend time
and the backyard was our place
we have that karaoke night almost all
the time when we're in the backyard
we learned a lot of card games everybody
was learning how to cook
and it was kind of like back to our safe
space the company's we're home
safe and sound from work headed to the
backyard
for a barbecue
but the backyard is my kingdom back
there do my grilling back there we're
gonna call this cookie with chocolate
i could smoke it i could bake it i could
fry it
whatever you want you can get it we
always wanted our backyard renovated
since we spent so much time back here we
just haven't had the opportunity
because we're always working during the
summer seasons
that's where we go to enjoy food music
and just relax
we've had a lot of fun but god has
blessed
us to raise three strong responsible
kids
that know the meaning of family
[Music]
i love this family so while the family
was having a good time at the park
they had no idea what was happening at
their house we sent an
entire team to dig up their lawn bring
in new appliances
and new patio furniture and the craziest
part we did all of this in just five
hours
look at this crew it actually took weeks
to set up but execute in five hours and
i can't wait to see their faces
when we reveal their new backyard to
[Music]
them